[Aplausos]
puede sonreír su partido de coalición
nacional ganó las elecciones
parlamentarias
orco dijo que negociaría con todos los
partidos para conseguir la mayoría en el
parlamento
[Música]
pueden ver que estoy muy contento es una
gran Victoria para la coalición creo que
los finlandeses quieren un cambio
ahora empezaré a negociar con todos los
partidos
Quiero crear confianza y colaboración
entre los partidos y construir un
gobierno de mayoría fuerte
cuando se publicaron los primeros
resultados que situaban al sdp En tercer
lugar la primera ministra saliente sana
Marín admitió su derrota al tiempo que
felicitó a los partidos ganadores es un
gran día porque lo hemos hecho bien en
las elecciones Enhorabuena también a los
demás ganadores Enhorabuena al partido
de coalición y Enhorabuena al partido
finlandés la democracia ha hablado el
pueblo finlandés ha votado y la
celebración de la Democracia es siempre
algo maravilloso
el siguiente paso para el futuro jefe de
gobierno es formar una mayoría en el
parlamento local el segundo puesto fue
para el partido finlandés una formación
de extrema derecha opuesta A la
inmigración y cuyos miembros podrían
formar parte del gobierno